Joseph's father is Jacob and
Jacob is the patriarch of Israel,
essentially that the
father of the 12 tribes.
And um,
we,
you might remember that,
uh,
he had a very morally
ambivalent halfway through life.
And it's one of the things that I think
so interesting about the stories in the,
in the Old Testament is that
these so-called patriarchal
figures are very realistic.
And it's something that I was also
being struck by that accounts in the new
testament that way.
There's lots of things that Christ does
that you'd think would have been edited
out over time and sanitize,
but they're not.
And the Old Testament is definitely
not a book that's been sanitized.
And that's,
it's quite interesting
that that's the case.
So you sort of see people with all
their flaws and I've been trying to also
derive some general conclusions about
the moral of the story of
the genesis stories and um,
because these stories are fundamentally
moral and moral as far as I'm concerned,
it has to do with action,
right?
Because moral decisions are the decisions
that you make when you're structuring
action.
When you decide to do
one thing or another,
generally want to do things that are the
best things that you can think of to do
and hence good.
But sometimes you also want to do things
that are the worst things you can do.
You know,
because you're angry
or resentful or bitter.
And so the moral decisions that you make
that govern your actions are really the
most important decisions
that you make in your life.
And it's not that easy to figure
out how to make moral decisions.
We don't have an unerring
technology for that the
same way as we do for say,
making decisions about empirical reality,
which in some ways seem a lot simpler.
Um,
partly because we can
work collectively at it,
partly because we have a rigorous
methodology for deciding what's true and
what's not.
So one of the things
that's really struck me,
like it's an overarching theme,
I would say that emerges out of genesis,
especially after the
really ancient stories,
uh,
say,
especially after the stories
of Cain and Abel and Noah and
the Tower of Babel.
When you get to the accounts of the
historically or historically real people,
one injunction seems to be get the
hell out there and do something.
You know,
one,
one of the major themes for all of the
Patriarchs that we've talked about,
Abraham say Jacob and Joseph is
move out into the world regardless
of the circumstances at hand.
Now that's in,
in in the Old Testament stories that's
basically portrayed as hearkening to the
voice of God.
Something like that.
Maybe you could think about that as
destiny or a psychological calling.
Um,
and the funny thing too is,
is that it's not that these people have
an easy time of it when they heed that
call.
So what's,
what's fascinating is that they often
run into extreme difficulties right away.
And I think that's very interesting.
First of all,
because life is obviously
full of extreme difficulties.
And second,
it's another example of the
failure to sugarcoat things,
which is one of the things that I
think makes a mockery of anti religious
theories that are even
quite sophisticated,
say,
like Freud,
Freud thought of religion as a,
as a wish fulfillment essentially.
And,
and also marked who thought about
religion as the opiate of the masses.
It's if those were true,
it seems to me that there'd be a lot
more wish and a lot less reality,
a lot less stark,
harsh reality.
No,
I mean,
the first thing that Abraham encounters
is a famine and then he has to hide his
wife and then he,
he basically journeys into a tyranny.
So that's about as bad
as it gets in some ways.
And those themes re recur continually.
And no one ever lives where
they're supposed to live.
They leave in live in Canaan
and not the promised land.
And so it's a pretty rough,
it's a pretty rough series of stories.
But the fundamental
idea is something like,
there's no time for sitting around.
There's time to go out
into the world and engage.